this year there were calls for police  reform protests occurred  nationwide including right here in las  vegas  all week we have been looking at what  changes metro police have made and what  changes still need to be made  tonight how does the department weed out  the bad apples  the sheriff has the authority to fire an  officer but can they appeal through  their union  there are times that they give people  their jobs back and  i i would be lying if i told you that  any of us was okay with that  but right now as things sit it's the  rights of these officers  tonight at five the i-team's george  knapp digs into what it takes  for an officer to get fired and how  often they stay  fired kirsten